Minky here.
Hello,
everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome in.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh, I opened up the first game.
Oh, my gosh.
Hold on.
I was about to say, you guys, I'm so tired.
the first game.
Sorry.
I'm so tired today.
I didn't even...
I was like, this looks a little different.
Oh my gosh.
The opening, the screen changes depending on where you are at in the game.
That's so cute.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
I'm really tired today.
I can't believe I did that.
Hi, everybody!
Welcome back to Half-Life 2!
Not Half-Life 1.
2!
Golly.
Oh, we were there!
We were right there.
I went there.
And then we did the epic boat adventure.
And I killed it.
I gamed all the way through!
The only thing they fear is Mickey Ripperter.
Yeah!
Are you the real Mint Phantom during this time of day in this region?
Localized entirely in this stream?
Yes.
May I watch it?
No.
Congrats on 400k.
Thank you!
I didn't actually get to properly say anything.
Thank you guys so much for 400k!
We did it.
Guys, I'm going to do my best today.
I hope I wake up a little bit.
I hope I wake up a little
bit.
Slept extra.
I said good.
You guys, I have a confession.
I said good morning, Minto on Twitter.
I got up, out of bed, posted that, and went back to sleep.
It was not morning for me.
I usually never post until I'm like, okay, I'm going to stay awake.
But that one...
I will.
I will have my privacy.
She's probably like, why?
She's so sleepy.
Did you sleep well, okay, Minky?
I slept too good.
Yesterday, yesterday, during the collab with Nimi and...
when we were playing Resident Evil I had a horrible midstream I had a horrible allergy attack I was like oh god it was so bad my nose was just going crazy and so after stream I took allergy medicine and that stuff knocks me the heck out and so I'm still feeling it I'm still feeling it look up five times for my alarm.
Still asleep at noon.
I never do that though for me.
Bill, thank you so much for the thank you to thank you.
It's my first night in Japan for my second trip here ever.
Facing fierce 3am battle with the jet hag.
Oh no, Todd.
I heard a steamed hams reference.
Yeah, that first, this is my trick for Japan is I try to arrive as soon as pot like okay so obviously on the plane if it's night in japan i sleep on the plane if it's day in japan i do my dangness to stay awake and then once i'm there i try to fly in as early as possible like 1 p.m 2 p.m ish maybe sometimes earlier if there's a fly and then and then i just i just sit i i i do whatever it takes to stay awake i'll walk i'll walk for as to just to stay out of my hotel room so i do not i'm not tempted by the sweet sweet seductress that is my bed so good luck were you up late last night playing gotcha oh no that was me get your sleep everybody get your sleep yeah but i've been there so many times at this point that it's like usually jet lag it depends on the trip maybe sometimes it hits me bad sometimes I'm pretty good new outfit and comic kit 106 this is going to be a packed weekend yeah my mama has comic kit merch everybody of me and other things if you are into the variety of thin books
that are of a certain devious nature.
My mama, oh my gosh, Ayami Mama's books, they're full color, they're so beautiful.
I recommend very, very, I mean, that's what made me a fan of hers to begin with, so.
Mint Dojin?
I would say 1 million, but I don't know if I'll ever get there.
So maybe 500k.
I'll ask Ayami Mama for a for official Minto Dojin.
Maybe I should aim high though.
That's pretty special.
So maybe...
Maybe we should aim big.
We're 100k though.
That's a long time from now.
Probably.
So...
Curious, have you ever spoken to any of your model sisters?
I've met Sleepy at the off-kai.
We hung out a little bit, actually.
For JP, though?
Not really.
I've been thinking.
I'm still not used to having thoughts, but I'm trying my best.
Make it 690K.
That's so goofy.
She's a gay Mercedes, so...
she's gaming she's gaming imagine sleeping resident music major in college oh when you said that i was thinking of the resident evil basement music
have you guys heard that resident evil basement music
but oh oh i forgot to mention also tomorrow new outfit of course also drawn by Ayami Mama and so
come see my new outfit don't forget it don't forget it don't forget new outfit debut yeah yippee yeah my first ever proper outfit debut which is kind of crazy and fun years oopsie oopsie oopsie can't forget those hips don't talk about my hips but you will see them but you will see them yes yes
yeah I don't know how long today will be I guess it really is just how much I can go for.
Let me drink some more coffee.
I have to sing, sing, Hips Don't Lie.
Hello, Minky, happy Friday.
Happy Friday.
Happy, happy Friday.
I hope you guys have a great weekend um i still have also stuff to prepare for for tomorrow i haven't prepared a single thing all my stuff kind of i was supposed to have merch that obviously didn't happen so i apologize that it'll just be me myself and i i apologize you made up it's so peak so you're fine am i or am I fine?
Oh my gosh, ghost of it!
I had the pleasure of meeting my fellow wisps at Otaku-tan last weekend.
Forget busting minto with glasses makes me feel good.
I'm glad you had fun at Otaku-tan!
My friend asked if I wanted to go to Otaku-tan next year, so I will try to be there next year too, make it this year.
Yeah, yeah.
A $50 fine.
Oh, no.
You fine.
So can you have a girlfriend?
Stop.
Now go tell her double.
Go tell her double.
You stole his girlfriend already?
Tee-hee.
All right, shall we get into it?
This is, I'm really enjoying this like swamp ASMR though.
Let's turn up a little bit.
We have a girlfriend, Vinky.
Hello, Ichiba and Minky.
I've been spending too much on Gacha lately, so I'm cleansing the bad energy by donating to a worthy cause.
Not the Gacha, no.
No.
Just got out of work and here's a cute Minky on my screen.
What should I give for lunch?
Open to haunt-based meal sharing options?
Friday lunch should be very special.
There's like a, there's a place by me that makes a sick fried rice.
I think I'm gonna get that today.
My diet!
I'll just pretend.
I'll just imagine the taste of the fried rice right now.
Oh.
Mmm, egg.
Mmm.
So yummy.
I'm full.
are you more of an inner voice thinker where you think in words and voice everything out in your head or a visual thinker i think i'm an inner voice thinker actually i'm an outer voice thinker i say everything i'm one of those that's that i'll be by myself and i'll be like oh i need to go do that I think.
I have an outer voice that I say everything that's like.
Did you talk to yourself?
Maybe.
I can't stop talking all the time.
I have a problem.
Maybe that's why I can yap so much on stream.
I'm currently sick, but I think a minke stream is a good way to feel better, by the way.
Congrats on Farakay.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm tired of what a leave work early.
No!
I mean, you could.
It's Friday.
Inner mouse, singer.
What does that mean?
I even enjoyed Half-Life 1.
You might check out Black Mesa.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
And thank you for congrats.
Thank you.
Lucky thanks for the five gifted to Agu.
Nah, I just yop about everything.
Talks to himself.
Keeps showing up.
my employment reviews.
I...
I guess, but I do in my head think of conversations and I'll be like
Good thinking me.
Good thinking, Boku.
Okay!
Someone's a xenomorph around here.
Oh my gosh, I saw a clip of that Alien Earth show.
I haven't watched it.
Did you guys know that there's Alien Earth?
It's a new Alien TV show.
And I guess the girl likes Ice Age.
And so sometimes I saw a clip of Ice Age Sid just appearing in the show.
I don't get it.
History Channel?
No, no, you know, Alien, like the movie, the horror movie.
And then they had the Alien Romulus.
And now there's Alien Earth.
The clip with Sid!
Disney owns Alien and Ice Age.
Wait, Disney does not own Ice Age?
No?
I thought Ice Age was DreamWorks.
Oh gosh, they're all owned by like the same five billionaires anywhere, no?
I don't know anymore.
But I thought Ice Age was DreamWorks.
There's a new alien show.
Wait, is that the same thing?
Are you going to try the new McDonald's shake?
Isn't that... Isn't people...
People are like acting like it's the new Grimmest Shake.
They're pouring it all over themselves.
Good morning, Miss Minto Freeman.
Rise and shine.
Thank you, Kamendachi.
Good morning.
When do we get alien isolation stream?
It's so scary, though.
It's so scary.
Ice Age was distributed by 20th Century Fox, who Disney owns now.
Oh, I see, I see.
I see, I see.
Okay.
Gosh, Disney owns...
my pinky toe too.
I saw the clip today.
I swore a pic was a joker for...
Yeah, me too.
I saw it today.
I was like, huh?
Huh?
It's time for tomorrow too.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
But, um...
Uh...
I don't remember where I was going with this.
Oh, I do remember though.
were talking about Disney and Alien.
Um, do you guys remember the Alien ride that used to be at Disney?
Do you guys remember?
And then it changed to Stitch Ride.
I like to watch videos of it.
I got to ride it.
I got to, well I say ride it.
It's really, okay, so basically I remember this so much because I got to ride it once as a kid alien encounter yeah yeah yeah i got to watch i got to i say watch it's not really a ride you just kind of sit there it's really it's really an experience i got to experience it once as a wee wisp and so basically i remember it so well and also i watch a lot of videos because of theme parks But anyway,
you go into this room and they're like, they are, they're, they, uh, I'm getting excited.
They're like, we have this new technology to teleport critters.
Let us teleport this critter to show you.
And they teleport this little guy.
And when he teleports into the other, into the other tube, he's all freaky and gross.
and they're like oh it's probably fine just go into the so that's like the pre-show right go that's the pre-show and then you go into the main room and it's a big like 360 room like then there's a tube in the middle and you sit in a chair and they're like okay now we're going to teleport the creature to you and you will see the creature and it's xenomorph it's so
from me okay and then things start getting crazy and the lights shut off and you start hearing like xenomorphs footsteps running around the room and you like you first hear the crash because she escapes from the pod and then you feel her breathing on your neck and and and then she spits on you oh my gosh i'm getting why'd they take it away from me from us oh my gosh Oh,
if only I had a time machine, it could go back in time and experience it again.
And then they changed it to Stitch, Lilo and Stitch.
So it was much more like kid-friendly because I'm in.
That ride traumatized me.
I loved it.
I, oh my gosh.
I probably talked about that ride a couple times a month for...
for even until now.
Oh my gosh.
And now, now it's like now there's, I think the setup for the ride is still there.
The experience is still there, but I don't think that they've done anything with it.
Oh, oh my gosh.
To me, Xenomorph to see her right in front.
Oh gosh.
Wow.
I recommend looking up a video, but it's really just like darkness.
most of the time.
It's just dark.
It was something that you can't really watch.
You have to only experience it.
It's how when they got rid of Muppet Vision.
Yeah.
The last thing Jim Henson worked on.
So sad.
Rainbow Connection.
Favorite part is that when the worker comes in from the ceiling and looks down at the audience, then gets crouched.
Ride it, please!
So good.
Sorry.
I go bonkers over this thing.
Why did they get rid of it?
Okay.
I'm good.
I'm chill.
I'm fine.
I'm okay.
Man.
Let's play game.
Maybe the coffee's hitting.
Okay.
So I had just solved this puzzle.
Because I'm so smart.
Oh no, I have to do the boat again.
Oh no.
Okay.
Let me turn it down a little bit.
Swamp goes.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Now that they actually own alien, it would be cool if they brought it back.
But with the actual alien IP instead of the original.
bug monster.
I want it.
I want.
Speaking about half-lives, Plutonium-238 has a half-life of about 68.9 years.
Nice.
About as old as Minto.
Hey!
Yeah, I did solve it.
Here we go.
Oh.
What movie, please?
Never knew you loved aliens so much.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
It's actually like...
I watch it all the time on the plane.
I think it's like one of the...
It's a perfect movie, honestly.
It's one of my favorite movies.
Here we go!
Oh.
Please.
Here we go.
Ah, ah, guys, guys, I think I'm in trouble.
Okay, okay, okay.
I have to remember the controls.
Here we go.
It's gotta be through here.
Never mind.
It's not.
Okay, why would they have this here then?
If we're not this being the way.
way to go
you're freeman aren't you yeah i wouldn't believe it if i couldn't see with my own eyes dr gordon freeman himself that's me wait am i actually done oh booty shot booty shot
we're just getting ready to pull out okay uh i'm stuck gotta tear down this camp and get out of here yeah i'm stuck i'm trying greetings to the freeman greetings to the I'll show you what you're up to.
Hello.
It's so cool to see him just down.
Wow, he looks at me with such disgust.
Whoa.
Okay, hold on.
I'm looking around first.
Let me look around a little bit.
Let me appreciate your abode.
Oh.
Okay.
Thank you.
He likes me.
Oh, he's shy.
He's shy.
Can't make eye contact with me.
Oh, with a big, big eye.
Wow.
Wait, he's actually so cute.
Ah!
He's so shy.
Why he kind of.
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, he's actually so cute.
What is the booty shot looking like anyway?
Not much going on in the back.
But he's got the big hump to make up for it.
Yeah, don't worry about it, buddy.
Okay, I'll come, I'll come.
I'll stop beating everything up now.
Hello.
Hello?
Here, take a look at this.
Oh, yeah?
This here's the dam.
It's just up ahead.
Eli's hideout is here.
throw from the apron and nestled in the old hydro plant where are we getting there with that hunter chopper on your ass next to impossible uh-huh good news is the vortigons working his magic on your airboat so you'll have a little more firepower going forward i think he's just finishing up now that was fast greetings to the freak mint yeah
hey i i tore down your body he looks so he's like wow why the fuck did she do this that he's like what the hell my boxes he looks so upset whoa what are you doing there there we are that gun came off one of the same hundred choppers that you're up against i always like to bring a little iron to a firefighter whoa take that chopper down and you should be able to tear on through the freeman will accept this weapon or suffer greatly on the road ahead so cute thank you thank you thank you that's a belly button so now we have a gun
thanks okay hold on f5 is is quick save f6 is quick save Okay, F6 is quicksand.
Get going, Doc.
We gotta break camp.
Okay.
Farewell, citizens.
For freedom!
Thank you, ma'am.
Oh.
I'm taking these with me.
They look...
Okay.
I guess I shouldn't waste my...
My ammo.
Oh wait, I have infinite ammo!
I guess I could have used the crates on.
That's so funny.
Oh well.
The music is so loud.
This way?
Ow!
Shoot!
I got- I know where I need to go, but...
Ah shoot!
Ah!
I'm stuck!
Please!
Oh please.
I need to remember how to pilot this thing.
Oh gosh I don't know how to file it I was doing fine until I was not Hold on Take it down anybody in my way Okay, we're fine Everything's good
I Um I don't know what just happened but We're fine Everything's good Everything's chill.
We were fine.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
Ouch!
Everything's chill.
Everything's fine.
Everything's cool.
Everything's chill.
Yeah.
If I just keep saying that, I know what's real, I know what's the truth.
Keep saying, everything's fine, everything's chill.
It's the truth.
Just keep going forward, baby.
Don't look back.
That's the motto.
This way!
Oh, that's awkward.
Okay, I see what I have to do.
Ouch.
Turn around.
We made it.
Easy peasy.
Wait.
Those good guys?
No, those were head crab guys.
I think.
Ouch.
Oh, we're fine.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
I missed my...
I think.
Actually, I don't know where I'm supposed to be.
No, we're fine.
I thought I was supposed to go up, but I think I'm supposed to go this way.
My health is not so great.
6 HP in a dream.
But it's nice and calm now.
Oh.
Where's it?
Drop me off at... Oh, right here!
This is...
Oh, but I have the 6 HP.
Will I be okay?
Will I be okay here?
How...
No!
There has to be health around somewhere, no?
Maybe...
I don't know when they'll get me.
And they'll start firing at me.
Oh,
here we go.
Aha!
Yeah, baby.
This should be better though.
Five HP more than you need to beat the game.
Six HP.
Enough to survive anything that shoots at me.
Okay.
Now, do I...
So I need to get in there?
I need to do the craziest jumps of all time, apparently.
Is that a ramp that I go up...
The ramp doesn't look high enough, though.
I once had to start a new game from this chapter because I was auto-saved with 15 HP before a ton of bullets and kind of soft-logged.
No!
Please don't stop.
Bam, if I need to save you guys, you guys, because you saw that when I died, it spawned me right there.
So, you know, I just did the auto-save, but it's okay.
I wasn't very far anyway from right this point.
Save us from how cute you are.
Oh, I see that guy.
Is he gonna see me?
You think I can get him from here?
Is that coming towards me?
Oh my god!
How did it do that?
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
How are they going crazy like that, though?
That guy, like, completely avoided the ship.
Okay.
Fireworks, baby.
Okay, we sniped one guy, so that's one down.
That's one down.
save just yet because, you know, I did get hit.
Not the honing missiles.
But there is a guy right here.
I'm like super taking it slow here.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my gosh.
I don't even know how he's seeing me.
Maybe okay, hold on.
There we go.
There are two boats!
Okay.
But I don't know where he is.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Oh, there he is.
Run!
Tactical retreat!
Oh my gosh, Tofu, thank you so much for the peek!
No!
Tofu, son!
Retreat, retreat!
Is it here?
Oh, I can't even reach that far.
Okay, that's why it was turning red.
Okay, Naruhoydo.
I learned.
Ah, the controls are still messing me up today.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
the bike or boat boat bike okay ouch oh it gets me every time
just hug the boat
did i get
him wait did that work wait i might have gotten him no way let's go wait this This might be health.
Yeah!
Okay, now we can do this part in peace.
I can figure it out.
Yippee!
How do I do this?
Do I get out of here?
And jump up there?
What?
There is...
I had a feeling there would be...
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
Is this actually a puzzle?
Looking around for more supplies.
Yeah, no help right now.
Let me figure it out.
If I can.
My brain is so slow today.
Oh, okay.
Too thick for that little area.
Oh!
I understand.
Oh, that's gotta be tricky.
It's common to get stuck here.
Wait, so can I not get up there at all?
Up top?
I thought I was going to have to be like...
Mimki doesn't need to hear all this.
She's a highly trained professional.
So true.
How do I get in there?
What?
Wait, oh, how do I get in there?
Oh, wait.
I just noticed it's closed off.
Ah.
Ha.
I'm making entrance.
Let's see.
We're swimming, we're swimming.
Yeah, I need to hit it a bajillion more times.
We'll get it.
I'm on the boat.
I'm on a boat.
Wait, can I jump up here?
I don't know if I can make that or not.
Oh wait, crouch jump maybe?
Okay.
I see it!
I see the salvation!
I'm exploring, I'm looking...
Early stream!
Thanks Minto, of course!
Thanks for watching!
I feel like it has to be here.
Oh wait, oh...
Nice.
How did I miss that?
Because I was looking at the container earlier to see if there was anything in it.
Oh, what?
Okay, back it up.
Back it up.
You looked at the other one.
Yeah, but I looked at that one, too.
I think I only looked at the front.
Woo!
Oh, we made
it!
We're fine.
For a degree.
Don't say Sasuga.
Don't say Sasuga!
Haha!
Easy!
This way.
More boating?
Will I ever get off this damn ride?
This area is so explore, Congrats on your Leon campaign.
Thank you.
Is that boss?
Uh-oh.
Are we bossing now?
Nice.
I remember this section being very long.
Oh, man.
Oh, we got little bit more suit juice I guess is
this part really hard I'm trying to I'm keeping an eye out oh yeah I see containers
more suit juice more suit juice nice what's this is that a grenade?
I want to get off Mr. Bones Wild, right?
That's exactly what I was thinking.
Hello, please.
I can't even...
I'm too used to the boat.
I can't even do a simple jump anymore.
Okay, we're almost 100, 100, so...
Maybe we'll be okay.
The game at least prepared us in that regard.
Let me check the other side.
Oh, I see more crates.
Suit juice?
Ahay!
Nice.
I'm not stalling, I'm preparing!
This is completely different.
And now we're at 100, baby.
Okay.
That's all I can do.
And now save in...
Iki match!
Oh,
there's barrels, okay.
We gotta blow something up.
Or he's gonna try and blow me up.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Him?
Wait, I'm stuck.
I don't even know it.
Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee.
Oh my gosh, how is he not blowing these up, though?
You know?
All of these...
We're out of soldiers!
I need to get out of here, I need to get out of here, I need to get out of here, I need to get out of here!
I don't think
I did at all a single bit.
Oh my gosh.
Where is he?
Oh there.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, no please, I think I just saw a crate, maybe I should have saved some crate, oh, 2 HP in a dream, ah ha ha ha, holy moly, this guy is tanky, what the heck, I
was close, dang, that guy was tanky, I was tanky, I was tanky, as heck.
So stinking tanky.
Okay.
Let's go!
No, that's a helicopter.
If I get rid of these first, though...
Oh, yep.
Ah, I was trying to leave.
Oh my gosh, I can't.
I can't drive this thing.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Like, if I blow these up first so that they... Oh, I see another one, too.
Oh, shoot!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Wait, did all these respawn?
Is it so?
Awesome?
Ow!
Oh, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Oh, we're not good.
We're not good.
We're actually in the worst possible predicament.
Shoot him while he's close.
Blow these up so that they don't blow me up instead.
Get out of here, get out of here, get out of here, get out of here!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, so much is happening.
I don't even know if I'm hitting him or not.
Where is he?
Behind me?
Oh.
I know it's kind of dumb to just sit still and let it happen, but...
Um...
Oh my god!
Please.
Spare me.
Oh my god.
What is he gonna start doing the...
dropping the bombs again?
Oh.
Please, uh...
Spare me!
Oh my god.
I'm in the worst possible place.
Maybe?
Wait, where is he, actually?
Oh.
Is he behind me?
Where?
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Ah!
Stop.
And I'm out of hell.
We did it!
Oh my god!
How did we do it?
Yippee!
I think there was health over here.
Or wait, I'll find it.
Wait, where was it?
No!
It's on the log.
Yeah, it's like somewhere over here.
I'm just gonna get off this wild ride.
Get me off of here.
Okay.
There it is.
Okay, thank you so much, bro.
Bye.
Oh, wait.
There was more underneath.
the thing, too.
Because I was full.
That takes care of the cremation?
Nice.
First try, baby.
Gamers helps just drop their next V cards at any chance you have a creator card.
Um, not me.
They've been sending me a lot of stuff for it.
Thank you so much for the pig, thank you!
Yeah, it was a first try.
Don't get it twisted.
That was the first try.
That wasn't so bad, he was just tanky.
Honestly, it...
The game was quite generous for health and everything.
And I'm stupid, I just sit there and take it.
I literally just tank it the whole time.
There's got to be some over here, too.
No?
Okay, it's not bad, Generos.
Game, I was hyping you up.
Damn.
So what's this?
Wait, what?
Why are you guys responding to?
Did Doki play this game?
Left of the game.
Oh, I see it.
Thank you.
I didn't...
I don't...
Oh, she...
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
I hate the ladders in this game.
It's...
It's Elp, but I'm blind, so it's fine.
Oh my gosh.
It's cool how you can...
Oh, please.
How you can see...
Sorry, I'll redo it.
But over there, it's, like, electrified.
That's so cool.
All just the small little details.
Chopper's ball spamming is actually a bug.
But Valve liked it, so they kept it in.
Oh, what?
So they hate us.
That's what you're saying.
I see a little ladder.
Oh, wait.
What's going on here?
What's going on?
Wait a second.
There's a lot going on here.
What's going on up here?
One.
Oh no.
Oh,
they use a gun again.
Oh, I just wasted that.
That's really unfortunate.
Where did you guys come from?
I deflect your bullets.
Uh.
Where are you?
Is it the guy from over here?
Wow, it's so beautiful here.
No?
Use the boat.
What a lovely sunset.
I feel like I have to go up here anyway, so might as well explore a little bit, huh?
Anyone else?
Okay.
Oh, whoa!
Hi!
Die!
Wait, oh gosh, I'm stuck.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, baby!
It was good we came in here.
Nice!
forgot how good the sound design in this game is it's nice right any buttons i could press i barely touched it
okay well we got some supplies that's always grand oh oh there's big stuff here
i think there's a ghost a ghost boost!
HP on the wall.
Thank you, I missed it.
I'm shoving my way through.
No, no.
This place is haunted.
Let's get out of here.
This place is haunted!
Yeah, I noticed all of...
I see I...
Wait, did...
Is that a person walking?
I thought I saw a person patrolling over there.
I wish I had a sniper.
That was G-Man!
No way!
Oh my gosh!
He's still watching me?
What a little freakazoid that guy is.
If
I go over, there.
Yeah, whatever.
I think I can get back.
Observation.
Oh, this looks like a battle area if I've ever seen one.
They're like, oh yeah, plenty of places for you to duck and cover.
Yeah, that's what I saw from the other side.
Gee, man, boss fight.
Yeah.
This is not a ladder.
If I go down, will I be stuck?
Is it?
Well, maybe it is.
Oh, it is.
It's just like the thinnest ladder I've ever seen.
He's preparing for your unforeseen consequences.
I think I need to go.
Is that like a limited time thing or...
This place is haunted.
for real I would know I would know it's just European European well
there's more bullets I guess then um we're good to go back down
Nothing.
Nothing, yeah.
Oh, what am I thinking?
We overwrote the gate on the other side.
Wait, there's an Easter egg here.
In the pipes?
Oh!
It's open.
I didn't think it was.
How do I get in there?
Maybe with that?
my boat push push push save before you go in you guys are scaring me but i appreciate very much the uh the warnings i still want to see it even if it kills me i like to see things you mentioned the vortigons belly button is it a belly button or is it a third armpit coming out of his his tummy huh okay oh my gosh this is tougher than it looks okay oh wait i made it
oh i see that
way i missed it
where to now and to what end discover the hidden sink Oh.
We remember the free man.
We are coterminous.
Hello.
There is no distance between us.
No false veils of time or space may intervene.
We see you still in black maize, sir.
Clearly we see you in the Nailin's chamber.
Chamber.
He is so cute.
Can I take your thing?
A finest poet describes it thus.
Ah!
I think I said something I shouldn't have.
Actually, yeah, I think it...
Is this your...
Oh, they're...
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to spill it.
Oh, he is chomping on them.
Nice.
Um...
I think I had a...
a piece of something you know when you make coffee sometimes and like sometimes the the little pieces get through at least for me I think I'm not good at making coffee this is more than anyone can bear but we will persevere persevere wait I got all this stuff but I still have to run back through the nastiness I still I still have to run back through this.
Yeah, the coffee.
Gap him harder.
We bear witness to the bright eternity of the Nailant's demise.
You leap, you fall, we see you flush between the barriers.
For a brief time you joined us, you are one between the worlds.
Yeah, I am, I am, I went there.
Communion of the Vortex.
just reload that's true but I want to talk to it I got the achievement well the achievement will still stay that's true we cannot forget those whose cords you cut forgiveness is not ours to bestow he's so cute I want to live here with you sorry I didn't mean to make it all crazy unity of purpose the shattering of common shackles a single road we tread your song we sing and shall sing for eternity no matter the consequences of this struggle.
You have brought us grief and jubilation beyond the measure.
The measure.
He sings in such a sing-songy way, or speaks.
We are there still in observance of your final stroke.
Stroke.
While our only scattered at your feet, you sieve at the voodoo cord that bound an ailment to life and to us.
To us.
That sharp spur of hope has not dulled to this day for once the lesser master lay defeated we knew the greater must also fall in time with you besides us a talisman of victory the day of freedom draws nigh he should start a YouTube channel of scary ghost video compilations number 13 we have survived worse across the ages your bright face obscures your darker mask yeah this guy's yapping we call you sib although your mind and meaning are a mystery to us to us what's sib far distant eyes look out through yours something secret steers us both We shall not name it.
We have endured these chafing bombs.
Do I need to keep talking to him?
Is something going to happen?
Can I leave?
Intolerable.
We are still here.
He sees us.
How do I...
I think it's F9.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, that was cool.
Glad that I still saw him.
Thank you for sharing the secret, everybody.
I like that.
He's just a yapper.
Wait, whoop.
Oh, there it is.
I see a ramp.
I go.
No, I don't.
Sorry.
She shoots.
She...
Uh...
Thank you for bringing Jubilation Beyond the Maja.
Okay, alright.
Heyyoo!
Good enough!
We made it!
Black Mesa East.
I see the symbol.
The symbol of my people.
Say goodbye to Bolt?
Is this it?
Is this where we Oh, boat.
Oh, boat.
Goodbye, boat.
One last donut.
Woo!
Okay.
Maybe a little dizzy.
I'm guessing this is where I was supposed to go, but let me check the other side.
Wee-boo.
Sick moves.
Thank you.
Yep, I knew it.
Move, please.
Contaminated area.
Hello?
You've got something.
Hi!
Okay, it's human.
Yes.
Well, ghosts.
Former human.
You'll have to forgive the scanning process.
We can't take any chances.
Okay.
Dr. Freeman?
Gordon Freeman?
That's me!
You've made it here this quickly, well Eli is going to be amazed, not to mention relieved.
I'm Dr. Mossman.
Yeah, I'm pretty fast.
I've been hearing about you since long before the Black Mesa incident.
I like how you can see her here too.
I do so envy you working with Eli and Dr. Clyde when they are at the top of their field.
Ah, there we go.
You can come through now.
Thank you.
You would never forgive me if I kept you waiting.
I'm used to that.
Hi.
Good to know you.
Thank you.
You'd better get going.
We can certainly use the extra help around here.
We've covered a lot of ground in the last few months, but things would be so much faster for you.
Poor people that you were trained.
This way, Dr. Freeman.
One moment.
I must inspect your facilities.
Okay.
Free meets Moss.
Moss?
Moss Burger?
We're closing in on a reliable local teleport technology.
Something the Combine still hasn't mastered.
Eli thinks their portals are string-based.
Similar to our Kalabi Yama.
Strand-based?
But they failed to factor in the dark energy equations.
They can tunnel through from their universe, but once they're here, they're dependent on local transportation.
If they knew what we were doing with entanglement...
Yes, ma'am.
Listen to me.
I sound like a postdoc.
I'm just so excited to think that we'll finally have the chance to work together I think she likes me.
Where was I?
It was coffin.
Oh, yes Dr. Kleiner compressed a Zen relay far beyond anything he imagined a black mason.
We've figured out how to use Zen as an unexpressed axis Effectively a dimensional slingshot so we can swing around the border.
We're so cute.
Come back in local space without having to pass through
oh here's a there he is all right good you keep right up Eli look who I found in the airlock hi Gordon Freeman let me get a look at you man my god you haven't changed one iota how do you do it now let's see the last time I saw you I sent you up for help after the resonance cascade yeah I never thought it would take you this long to get back to me welcome to the lab anyway Black Mesa,
but it served us well enough.
It's going to be a lot more like Black Mesa with Gordon here to help.
Right, you are.
MIT graduates are few and far between these days.
We'll get you out of that hazard suit and back into your lab coat where you belong.
What?
Let me just finish up some work and I'll see what I can dig up.
Dr. Freeman, it's been a real honor.
I'm looking forward to working together.
I think she likes me.
Feel free to look around.
I will.
Hi, buddy.
Oh, did you just shoot me away?
The Eli Vance has earned our trust.
Oh, he's trying to kiss me.
You remember my wife, Ozzy, and don't you?
Aw.
That picture and Alex were all I managed to carry out of Black Mesa.
Eli saw me looking.
Looking what?
Looking at what?
They...
Hmm.
What's that?
It's in here.
It's locked.
Oh!
The Vortigant said you were here.
I can't believe you made it so quickly on foot.
I'm just that good!
I believe he broke your record, honey.
Well, he earned it.
I guess you proved you can handle yourself out there.
There's nothing Gordon can't handle, with the possible exception of you.
Dad, please.
Ah!
Did he just wink at me?
Sir?
Where are we going?
Take a look at this, Gordon.
She's on top of me.
Holy cow!
Woo!
I'm taking a look, sir!
Give me...
Wow!
Oh!
What changes?
Alex, I thought you were on watch.
The Vortigons relieved me so I could come see Gordon.
Anyway, I should be in here working on the portal.
I am doing science.
Someone misjudges capacity of the Combine Thyristor.
Are you blaming me?
No, not at all.
It was a calculation error, not a mechanical problem.
Then maybe you should let me do the calculations next time as well as installing it.
Alex, really?
Sometimes I think you deliberately misunderstand me.
Ladies, ladies.
Why don't you take Gordon along and give him some practice with the gravity gun?
No.
Sure.
Come on, Gordon.
Oh, no.
Let's go have some fun.
The zero-point energy field manipulator is not a toy, Alex.
Let's get out of here.
Not the gravity gun.
I thought we were having a staring contest for a second.
See you in a little while, Gordon.
See you!
I'm just checking the place out.
out there's a lot going on here so i see you've met dr mossman she's one of the main reasons i spend so much time outside you should hear her drone on about how it should have been her in the black mesa test chamber i like it you sure okay i'm sorry i shouldn't be talking behind her back it just gets a bit claustrophobic down here spill the tea sis that's the old passage to raven home
anymore come on i'm wait not you you're the one reminiscing
we don't go there what if i went there
something's making noises in here mysterious i think we have an intruder
it sounds spooky down there Don't go there.
Hello.
You alright?
She seems a little traumatized.
So, here we are.
The scrapyard.
This is a gravity gun my father was talking about.
You can call it a zero-point energy field manipulator if you really want to.
It's designed for handling hazardous materials, but we mainly use it for heavy lifting.
Give it a try.
Get the gravity gun.
The primary trigger emits a charge.
You can punch stuff and send it flying.
I found it handy for clearing minefields.
So how do I use it?
Boom!
The secondary trigger lets you grab things.
You can throw them with the primary.
Once you've picked something up, you can drop it gently by pressing your secondary trigger again.
Pick up some stuff and toss it.
Oh.
Oh!
Guys?
Is this fake rock?
Is it like a wallpaper?
Oh, my God.
Try grabbing those barrels from that ledge up there.
All right.
Oh, I threw paint!
Oh, it was paint!
Oh, cute!
See if you can stack some stuff to climb up here.
Good enough.
Yeah, yeah.
We're gaming.
I like the sound it makes.
I'm working on it.
Grab something with your secondary trigger.
Then press the same trigger again to drop it gently.
I'm working!
Get on it!
You are a Jedi now.
I saw some people saying there was a secret here too.
I will search.
How far can we grab?
Wow!
Crazy!
Far!
Now it feels like portal for real.
Yeah, it does have some range.
Does it have like a charge or anything to it or can I just...
Go baby, go.
Oh no, was it up there?
Wait a second.
Oops.
Soup?
What about soup?
Why are you guys saying that?
No ammo needed.
To my right, that one over there?
Why are you guys saying soup?
By the white door.
Okay, I thought it might be another tunnel thing.
Tunnel situation.
There's even a toilet in here.
I hope I didn't need that.
This G-Man's toilet.
Wait.
Oh, I need to get up here.
Come on.
Oh wait.
Maybe here.
I need a bigger.
Bigger.
Oh!
No, I fell!
No!
Oh, man.
How did that happen?
Oh.
Take two.
Okay.
Um, let's do this one instead.
Okay, oh, oh,
that's the Easter egg, the panel.
Oh, find the HEV suit charger faceplate in Eli's scrapyard.
Oh.
Mmm, soup is what the grab gun says when you click.
How do I flip it over?
Oh!
Cute!
Sorry, I'm okay.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna hear mmm soup every time now.
That's so silly.
Okay.
Well, thank you guys for the Easter egg.
That was fun.
Thoroughly enjoyed myself.
Beware of dog.
We got a dog here.
Oh, I didn't even...
Wow, I'm so extra.
Hello.
Now let me call dog.
He loves to play fetch.
Dog is his name?
Is it a human?
Dog!
Good doggy.
Gordon, this is dog.
I want to see the new outfit now.
Be patient.
First model was about yay high.
I've been adding to him ever since.
Haven't I, boy?
Dog!
Okay, dog.
Let's play catch with Gordon.
Yeah.
You'll need to use a gravity gun.
Okay.
Go ahead, dog.
Throw.
Oh my god, he has his old little dog house.
Oh, I thought he wanted a big...
Um, big something.
What is it?
Oh, this is so cute too!
Oh, throw another dog!
Okay, okay.
Why doesn't he, why doesn't he pick it up?
Meow!
Go ahead, dog.
Throw!
I knew it was this.
I knew it.
What is that thing?
Get it, boy.
Do it, dog.
I got I know I throw it.
You catch.
You fetch.
Ah, we're playing game.
This is the game.
He got it.
We're playing catch.
Where do we get?
I didn't tell you who'd be fetching.
Ouch.
Where'd he go?
How much longer do I have to do this?
So did...
All right, Gordon, let's try something else.
Dog, throw something bigger.
Bigger?
What's then there in your...
in your dumpster of dreams?
Is it empty?
Oh, he's so cute.
No, Dog.
No, no, boy.
Get down.
Put that down.
Oh.
What is it, Dog?
Oh no.
Oh my god, what was that?
Temper tantrum?
Scanners?
Oh, the combine's sweeping the area.
We've got to head back to the lab.
Come on, Gordon.
Oh my god.
Uh-oh.
Alex, you good?
Dog!
Get inside, dog.
What's going on in there?
Where are you, Alex?
We're in the scrapyard airlock stuck in a full auto cycle.
Is Gordon still with you?
He's right here.
Hi.
Two, two, two.
Take Gordon out of here.
Head for the coast.
No!
Do not go through rape.
Dad?
Dad!
Damn it!
Dog, open the airlock.
Get us out of here.
Dog?
Uh-oh.
That's enough, dog.
Wait, dog's coming with you.
Come on, Gordon.
Come on!
I'm trying.
I'm trying to move.
I've tried... I... I can't... Okay.
You're coming with us, right, dog?
Oh my god.
He's the one causing the avalanche.
I can pick him up!
Gordon, you need to get out of here.
I can't leave my father.
Dog, take Gordon to the Ravenholm tunnel and circle around and try to meet up with me.
Hurry!
I can pick it up!
Where did she- where did she sit?
Oh my god.
It's suddenly so loud.
Where- what she said- Oh but we- oh- Is this a-
But I was told no!
He said go through, right?
What's Ravenholm?
You guys are scaring me!
You're about to find out.
Oh, baby.
Stop.
How do I get through?
Oops.
Wait, was I supposed to jump on top of that?
I sure hope not.
I did just save you guys, please.
It's okay.
Left click the green thing.
Oh, I forgot that I can left click.
Thank you.
Like, I knew that I could pick up stuff up and left click, but I forgot that I can just left click.
That doesn't seem good, right?
They're not watching for you?
What a thrill.
What killed the head crab?
I'm so scared!
What a thrill with darkness.
And silence for the night.
A gun!
We don't go to Raven home.
Thank you.
This is my favorite part of this game.
Remember when you said Half-Life 2 felt like a horror game?
I can't...
Oh my gosh, the music is so loud.
Oh!
Are those Pats?
I keep hearing talking, but I can't tell if it's like a guy's radio or what, you know?
Because the music is so stinking loud.
Is this suddenly a horror game for real?
Look at them Pats!
Ooh.
Ooh, buddy.
It's a fun challenge to try to use only the gravity gun here.
Okay, I'll try.
Oh, wait, this is real.
Oh, my god.
How am I supposed to use the gravity gun on this man?
Anything I can pick up and throw at you?
Oh no, it's suddenly zombies.
I'm playing Resident Evil again.
Throw objects.
But what can I throw at him?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, bye.
See that sign.
I got it before you guys even said anything.
Uh-oh.
Zombie game time?
Why can't I pick up people?
Look at the claw.
Wow.
Oh, come here, come here.
Ha!
Soon?
Okay.
That guy looks alive.
Come here, come here.
Oh, how could I I missed.
Oh, wait.
That's exciting.
Um.
Oh, my God!
Whoa!
I just realized what happened to him.
Whoa.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, can I please get through here?
It's kind of sick chat
going feral with the back seating you guys good not even looking you guys good let me i just got the gun let me try it out geez i just got it
oh my gosh
Where'd the saw go?
Saw?
Hey, back off!
Back off, buddy!
Where'd the saw go?
That works.
You have other guns?
Yeah.
I know, but I wanted to try and see if I could get the achievement.
Let's see.
Look, here's one.
Oh, there it is.
It went under the top.
table, that's why.
Okay.
Toofer!
Nice.
Run away, run away, run away.
Wait, this way?
I kill him.
Sometimes they survive, and sometimes they don't.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we're getting it, we're getting it.
Let's take the other one, too.
Oh, okay, these are all flammable.
I could have just used that.
So freaky.
Where'd the other one go?
Oh, there it is.
I'm, like, collecting supplies to grow.
Was it burping?
Okay.
I don't know how to do that.
Oh, come on!
Wait, this is kind of great, no?
Who said that?
Anything in here?
Oh!
Stop, stop.
I am.
Oh,
it's so gross.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I'm being a little baby about this all.
I'll keep going.
Where?
Oh, there.
Oh, seriously?
Um.
Oh, they throw stuff too.
That's why we played cat.
I could turn it off or
I lost my saws you guys I have nothing
there will be more will there wait I think I had one left here okay
okay let's go I
saw one For the days of my life has vanished like smoke, and my bones are parched like ash, and let all my impurities be as fuel for that fire and for nothing remains.
Oh, there's many more!
Let's go.
Oops.
Spin to wean.
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him coming.
Oh, my gosh.
Where'd you guys come from?
Over here.
Oh, I see you, I see you.
And a little...
Oh, gosh!
Did I get him?
I think so.
Okay.
Lucky.
Lucky, lucky.
I didn't even see these...
Ah-ha-ha.
They were having a little...
feast, eh?
I see.
What the?
Where did...
Holy cow!
Where did he come from?
Wait, was he... No, that guy was killed.
Okay.
Area is so scary.
You love physics.
Beat!
Two!
Oh shoot.
I forgot that.
Ow!
Leave me alone.
Oh!
That got me a little bit of that.
I'm just gonna get more health.
Overkill.
For a single head crab?
Never.
Head crab's evil.
I hear them.
They're so scary.
May they become like dust before the wind.
May the angel of the Lord pursue them.
Oops.
Ow!
Hey!
You chill out.
There you are.
Come here.
No, no, no.
Come back.
Wait.
No, no.
Come back.
What's going on in there?
Hot dog!
Imagine experiencing all those physics in 2004.
Crazy, right?
Whoop!
Are your head crabs okay?
I guess that guy's dead.
He's not moving.
Leave me alone!
This guy's dead.
He's fine.
Okay.
Do I get the achievement if I use my...
This?
Now I just realize.
Did I just ruin the...
Did I kill the achievement?
Vivikor, thank you for the five gifted.
It's okay.
I like learning the gravity gun anyway.
Oh, wait.
So it's okay.
Oops.
know there was achievement.
That's what people were saying.
If I use the gravity gun this whole section, I'll get an achievement.
I kind of wanted to try for it.
But it's okay.
I'm not so serious about that stuff anyway.
Yeah, it's all good.
I just wanted the challenge.
Oh, it's too far.
Oh my gosh.
It's so creepy.
Oh, he's dead.
This area what the hell do I even need this everything is flammable
oh there he is are you shooting at me hi well who is this another life to save yeah I'll keep my eye on you more than What if I kill him right now?
Cool, let's go.
He just keeps this perpetual fire going to protect himself.
That's kind of genius.
The best barbecue in town, baby.
Um,
where did my thing go?
I think I have another saw over here.
There it is.
anything over here i don't
have anything to shoot you with where's my saw stop giving me
stop giving me health my gosh Ouch!
Oop!
Nice slice.
You could use the med kit.
I'm actually okay.
That's why it's not using it.
They just sound like crying babies.
It's so creepy.
Wait, so if I...
Okay, okay, okay.
I thought that was the case, but...
I wasn't sure if I needed to go through here either.
Oh god, it's so scary.
Nope.
Well, that explains it.
There's nothing in here.
Took gold through.
Oh!
Is that gas?
Overkill, baby!
Oh!
Oh,
I guess a knob would have done it, too.
Oh, well.
It's got his little, like, butcher area.
This is pretty messed up.
Fire.
Fire!
Nice.
Do we go through the spooky dark passageway or do we go through the lit passageway?
The lit passageway that leads to the man that is alive and well.
I keep hearing them.
They're so scary.
Let's try the spooky dark way.
Let's try the lit way.
Bunk.
Slowly but surely.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Ouch!
Jerk!
I missed.
Come here.
Oh, tiny scrap.
No, needed.
Big scrap.
Needed.
Is that a guy in there?
I'm just pushing all of this over.
That's it.
He gave up.
Will this reach in there?
One way to find out.
Oh, it did!
Wow!
Lending my hand.
There's another guy in there, though.
I see it.
I don't think that worked.
Oh well.
What's up here anyway?
What is all this?
You sure you're dead?
He's just moving furniture.
He's trying to barricade the door to keep the Freeman monster out.
Headcraft victims are still conscious but trapped in their bodies.
They feel everything.
Those moans are a reverse speech?
What are they saying?
Oh, I want my saw back.
Help me in reverse?
Ew!
Ow!
I didn't think that one through guys.
My bad.
All right.
We should leave.
It did to me sound like they're going like, oh god, no, oh god, that's what it sounded like to me, but if it's reversed, that makes sense too.
There was a whole party going on there.
These are dangerous to have, but...
Yeah, stupid.
instead.
Nice reflexes.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh, I missed.
Oh, I thought it would be a bigger explosion.
Oh, no.
There's my saw.
We're fine.
Oh, I keep pressing the wrong thing.
Because I don't want to, like, accidentally...
What's the word?
Press...
You know if I'm, like, trying to...
set it down but i accidentally throw it and then explode myself you know that's what i'm trying to not have happen that's what i'm trying to avoid so yeah i feel like it will happen i mean yeah
so i'm more cautious about pressing The right button, then the left, you know?
Just to make sure.
The splash damage.
Oh, my gosh.
What is that?
Wait, what the hell?
What is this?
I got a gun.
Oh, no, it's those.
What does that mean?
I haven't saved in a bit.
Let's do that.
Thank you so much for the thank you, thank you!
She peeking.
I'm just, I'm admiring this lovely night.
I'm not gonna lie, the sound of the gravity gun does kind of get annoying.
Like that, zoom, zoom, constantly.
Constantly feel like I need to lower the volume.
What do I do?
go from here?
Oh, I guess?
Oh, that that secret, not secret area, the uh, the area that I turned off the fire before.
Oh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Oh.
It's the poison guys, are you dead?
They're poison?
Oh!
Oh
my gosh, there's more guys coming, please!
I killed all you!
Are you dead yet?
These guys kind of suck.
Are they only in this area?
Please say yes.
No!
Boo!
Well, we'll get through it.
We'll get through it, I believe.
I keep being paranoid because I keep thinking I'm hearing guys going, I mean, they're everywhere, so I'm going to hear them, but...
Okay.
Okay, maybe I can lead them into killing both of them at once.
Oh, all three of them.
Okay, come on, come on.
Come here.
Oh,
that doesn't work anymore.
Just kidding.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
There he goes.
Woof!
Thanks, guys.
I probably killed all the head grabs that were alive.
Oh, Mr. Priest, you gotta let me in?
You gotta let a gal in, please?
I'm hearing someone.
Oh, golly.
What's that sound?
Oh, that was me losing my, my saw.
That's fine.
I suppose.
I'll be safe on the roof, really?
Is that true?
Do I just jump over there?
Actually, I guess so.
Oh, hi.
Well done, brother.
Make free use of my traps.
But take care not to fall in them yourself.
Behind you.
you do well to be vigilant um
where do i go anyway
i'm here uh sir where do i go
i'm uh miyoto is blind moment happening at the moment platforming time but i don't wait is it over here oh Oh, I see, I see, okay.
I almost missed it, for real.
Oh!
I see her.
Oh, did I...
Where's the gamer yellow?
Yeah!
Oh, gosh.
I don't know if...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I'm glad I can at least use it on these guys.
It's nice.
Except when they miss.
Quispy.
Like I did?
Oh.
I'm locking on something.
Hmm.
Okay.
Let's go.
Locking it on something.
I can't tell what, though.
Hmm.
That's not a door.
Oh, sick.
There's a crab in here, maybe.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
It's so creepy.
Hearing them just moaning.
I don't like it.
it.
Wait, is this a trap?
What does it do?
I guess we'll find out.
Oh, geez.
I missed.
Um.
Well, it would have been really nice to know what it did.
Uh, shoot.
I'm trapped.
Um, I'll loop them.
Where do you go?
At least they're going to run eventually.
Don't tell me that they're going to run eventually.
Ouch.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Don't smile.
You're scaring me.
Who's this angel?
Oh, my mistake.
It's a cute girl.
I need
you all to come here
Just keep lifting and just wait They never learn
Good Does this work?
Nope, okay
Okay, it's back up, so I have to remember that.
It's the zombie flattener.
I...
Okay.
Oh!
Let's go...
You guys say puzzle time, but I don't even know what the puzzle is?
Oh, I can't go this way.
Okay, puzzle time!
Do I need to...
Go, uh, here?
I got stuck here for 10 minutes?
Crazy.
I'll double that time.
No, triple.
I think I need to jump on top of the cars.
Oh, but how would I... Maybe this one.
God.
Got it.
I guess I need to go up there, so we go here, and...
How do I get over... Oh!
So scary when it's dark!
Mito's so smart.
I'm overthinking it?
Am I for real?
Oh, I think I am.
Wait, am I?
How do I get up there, though?
Now I overthink, of course.
I wish that it wasn't so dark.
I also don't know where...
I feel... That's where I need to go, no?
This is just a secret.
Oh, really?
Oh.
This isn't where I need to go?
Oh, I just did- did it on- Oh!
The platforms could use more yellow.
Better and better.
I am Father Gregory.
You have already met my congregation.
Very funny, mister.
Are you in here, or...
Oh.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I knew that was gonna happen.
We're fine.
Or it's dead, right?
I could have used your help like two seconds ago.
Ah!
How is he so fast?
Oh!
It is you, brother.
I apologize.
I'm stuck on the door.
I'm stuck on the...
Head grab!
Oh my gosh, please.
I wish I could pick them up.
Door's stuck!
Please, Mr. Help me!
Oh.
Oh, this is so funny.
It like reloads the thing.
We didn't have gamer paint.
We had to walk uphill to Ravenholm.
Both ways.
Okay, run.
Wish I could see anything.
Oh gosh, I hear him.
Yeah, don't come at me.
Oh, ew, nasty.
That thing's huge.
Where'd the others?
Oh, that's a gun.
Oh, it's just two of them.
Ah!
You're not supposed to jump at me while you're on fire.
Does it not burn?
Just chilling.
Oh, there he goes.
About time.
I have nothing else to throw.
I have a paint can.
And a dream.
Oh, I lost my paint can!
Have a chair?
Please, Mr. Oh, my God, I lost it.
Ah!
Wait, it's in your block!
What just happened?
Wait, what just happened?
There we go.
Explosive chair?
For real, though.
Was it because I parried?
Whatever you threw at me?
Maybe I should just go down.
Will they fall?
No.
Ah!
Yeah, boy!
So true.
So, how?
I don't quite understand why it exploded, but it worked, I suppose.
Longest, yeah, boy!
Over here?
No.
Oh.
Nice, lucky.
We take what we take.
I think there's a cheeky little ladder.
There's a ladder somewhere?
Or...
Do I...
Do I need to get on to...
Oh, I think I do.
Okay.
I do need to maybe get back up there somehow.
It's a big ladder?
Did I miss it?
I mean, clearly I did.
Actually, I did.
Honestly, it would have been way better to get down here before because they are not as ganged up right now.
Oops!
That's not what I meant to do.
Yeah!
Boy!
I lost it.
Yeah!
Booy!
Oh!
Is he on fire now?
Oh, is this him?
All right, where's the ladder at?
The brick is the best.
It's not big.
It's effective ladder.
What do you mean, but...
Why would I be...
Kidding with you guys here?
The glasses aren't working!
Where did it?
Where is it?
Down the hill.
Wait, can I...
Never mind.
I thought there was something maybe over here.
Uh...
No, that's not it.
I see it.
Okay, but you guys can't be like, man, but I wasn't even in the right area.
Of course I'm not gonna see it if I'm not in the correct spot.
Like, that'd be craziness, no?
Yeah.
I wasn't even in the rider.
Oh, no, they call me crazy.
I care much, for thou art my helper.
My strength and my strength.
Ah, good.
I need the gamer pant.
It's literally made for me.
Oh, whoops.
Oh.
This little piggy.
Okay, I think they're all dead.
This Goldilocks up in here.
For real.
Whoa!
Oh, gosh.
Um, I lost the saw.
But we still have...
Cinder block?
Cinder block.
Uh, we don't...
have the cinder block anymore either there was one in here she looks so scientific it's on the stairs what the hell mister
oh there it is
don't grab me
oh there it is it was not on the stairs Unless you were talking about the cinder block.
Then you're correct.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
That's a whole lot of health.
A whole lot of items.
Van, thank you so much for the peek.
Thank you.
That's a lot of stuff.
What do you mean it's time, lads?
What do you mean?
Please
come back
They looked like Spider-Man
That's me That's me Use guns now Ow Okay I'll use guns No Spider-Man's a good guy Which gun should we use?
This one?
I guess I already missed the achievement, so...
No, but look at all of these!
That I can't use.
What's the point of having so many washing machines if they are not for...
Picking up and throwing?
Gosh, they take a lot of hits, though.
It's gonna turn down.
Or I could just one shot him with a saw.
Too heavy since when?
What's all this ammo that I'm trying to pick up but I...
I...
I guess maybe this?
My pistol?
Pistol and revolver?
Revolver I can only hold 12?
I like this because I can just kind of blast them.
You know?
It's pretty easy.
Let's grab this real quick.
Why not?
Wait.
Is there anything behind here?
Any secrets?
It's in your cart?
What if you...
What if there was a little secret?
snake in there.
Just a box, actually.
For once, just a box.
Now we'll go with the pistol.
He isn't enjoying himself.
Oh.
Is he gonna help me?
Are we gonna fight together?
Hi, it's me!
Come closer.
I'm here.
You've stirred up hell.
Man after my own heart.
Hey!
What was that?
You'll need it.
Catch.
Good.
Now, keep it close.
What is this?
Oh, sorry.
Aim for the head.
Hush.
They come.
There is.
Aim for the head.
There is no rest in Ravenhorn.
Move on and I will meet you at the church.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Where is it?
Jesus!
I'm gonna die to a head grab!
I...
I lost everything!
What did we...
What did we get?
What did he give us?
Well, I don't have any ammo for it, so nothing, I suppose.
Do I have to go all the way back to...
Where the hell did you guys come from?
Where did you come from?
I'm not having you sneak up on me.
It was four?
Oh, it won't let me select it then.
Probably because...
Okay.
Probably because I have no ammo.
Let's just see how far we can get.
I don't remember when I last loaded, I'll be honest.
Is there any health back here, maybe?
Play them all, or will you summarize?
summarize metal gear.
You're just gonna have to play all of them.
Oh my god.
Because I wouldn't have me.
Oh, there's some.
Okay, so four.
Was the shoddy.
I wouldn't have me fall because that, obviously, we saw what happened to me.
I guess maybe I go down and around over there.
Oh, there's so many down there.
Hold on, I'm just getting my bearings.
Okay.
Maybe I was supposed to go down.
I just, you know, messed it up.
Jump on the water tank?
Can I make that?
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Ah, I see.
There's nothing in here, right?
Oh.
Oh gosh, that scared me!
Oh, the game new!
The game new!
Holy!
I hear him climbing.
I think I'm gonna save.
It might be a mistake, but I think it might be fine too.
Who knows?
Wait, there's supplies in here!
Okay, maybe it's fine.
Oh, that's not supplies.
And there's gravity gun things, supplies in here.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for whoever's in there.
Oh my gosh.
No.
Where?
There it is.
Oh, you're fine.
Close the door.
Good plan.
Oh, there was nobody in there.
I didn't lose that much health, so...
Oh, wrong.
Wait, there it is.
Okay.
Oh no!
Mouse 2 with shotgun fires double shots.
Okay, I did accidentally shoot double shots earlier.
So, um...
Uh-oh.
What the hell is that?
Well, he's on fire.
Oh my gosh.
I don't have any more shot than bullets?
They're fast.
Oh, geez.
The game knows.
Okay.
I don't like it.
I like it.
Okay, okay.
All right, we're fine.
Maybe.
I need to stop saying that, huh?
I see this, by the way.
Don't worry.
I do see it.
Oh, that was that guy dying, maybe.
Okay.
Oh, and this is a dead end.
Woo!
You can see.
Squirm.
I'm just gonna get it preemptively.
I pressed four earlier, you guys.
And it would not...
It would not equip it.
That's so weird.
But now when I press it, it does.
Huh.
That's weird.
The gun was empty.
But I didn't just pick up bullets.
Because I had no ammo.
When did I just pick up ammo?
I didn't.
No, I mean like just now.
You know what they're like?
They are like the...
Oh my gosh.
They're like the um...
The cows in MGS4.
Who's throwing that?
Oh my gosh.
Who's throwing all this?
I'm waiting.
Tactical.
They're not coming until I go, are they?
Okay.
I get it.
I understand.
I saw them.
Oh, they're over there, aren't they?
Yeah, maybe I'll just bring it with me.
There's some up there, too.
what
did i hit that was so close to me are you kidding oh well he was right behind me so that makes sense was it the wall oh i thought i had my gravity gun out um uh i'm just gonna die so that i can reload okay i thought i had the gravity gun out Look at them go.
Look at them go.
They're just pushing around everything.
I don't like it.
Oh, they come from here too!
Where'd the other things go?
Not even two shots?
Get some?
Ouch.
I'll try to switch between the two so I don't just waste you know we're jukein' them we're jukein them
guys I think I know what buttons switches the buttons they don't need to tell me I think I oh that's a guy I think I know what buttons changes the guns I think I'm good thank you
Okay, and oh, more of them, but so many.
Oh, oops, I thought I changed.
I did press G.
Whoa, whoa, where'd he go?
Killed him, though.
I got his butt.
Ah!
I wish these guys dropped stuff.
so used to, what's it called right now?
Resident Evil.
It's never ending.
Um, I know what I'm gonna do.
Oh my gosh, there's so many of you guys!
Ah!
He was too close to me!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Do I just need to go through this area?
Oh wait.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, they really are never ending!
Where'd it go?
Oops.
I missed.
I, uh...
Come here.
Ah!
I'm so bad right now.
I'm so angry.
I'm so angry!
Gamer rage.
I'm never, I'm always too far.
I'm always too close.
It's never, it's never in between.
It's never, I can never read it.
I can never read it well.
Yabba-dabba-dabba.
Is this all contraption?
Right now, I'm just trying to survive, man.
I'm just trying to...
I'm just trying to survive!
There was a lever up there, was there?
Oh, thank you.
So I was right about a contraption happening.
Lever.
I don't see it.
On the balcony?
Which one?
I was looking for something on the wall, okay?
Not on the ground.
Why am I on this gun?
Oh, I don't have any shotgun stuff left.
All right, we're revolving.
It's not as good as I would wish it to be.
All right.
Take two.
I...
Okay, but that one was my fault.
So that led over there, okay.
I think we need one more.
Wow, they really just don't stop coming.
I'm just looking around.
Oh, please, you guys!
Oh!
Somewhere?
Ah-ha!
Okay, okay.
I knew that was going to open at some point.
How...
There was...
Um...
I thought there was one more spot I hadn't gone inside.
There?
Yes.
No.
Uh...
Oh, my gosh.
You can shoot Oreo barrels.
I can't tell if you're being sarcastic or not.
Okay.
I can't tell.
I feel a little trapped.
I think they're endless, and that's why I'm not even bothering with them anymore.
If I go back up here, there was nothing.
How do I get up?
Me and ladders, my greatest nemesis.
Me finding ladders.
Yeah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
This part's so evil.
Okay, no ladder there.
I kind of want to restart it, but we've already gotten this far.
Because I didn't realize that they were endless, so...
Head north.
Okay.
Oh, they're all gone now.
I think they all just follow each other.
I wish I could just climb up that guy.
Oh my god.
Do I have one HP?
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna lose it.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh, there's so many of them!
I hate this!
Oh, screw!
Screw this whole section.
Ah!
It's a dead end!
What?
What was-
Climb?
Where?
This?
I saw a ladder right there.
Oh wait, Elman.
Oh my god.
This is it, boys.
Oh, I see it now.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh, this part is so evil.
Oh, it's so evil.
Oh, I didn't hate the game until now.
I didn't hate the game until now.
I didn't hate
the game until now.
knows holy cow the game knows let the hate flow through you i saved though especially because is he throwing stuff up here look at all this the game knows they're just like okay you've been through a lot buddy you've been through a lot we get it
i can't tell
Okay, anyway, um...
If they didn't want you to use the quick save, they wouldn't give it to you.
That's right.
That's right!
How are you still alive?
Oh!
Quick save.
I picked
up something.
Yes, give me more ammo.
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Did he miss?
Ow!
I'm going!
Who's shooting?
Oh, here they are.
Oh, I should be...
Okay, I understand what I was supposed to do.
Like, I should have taken that and...
Okay, I'm just...
Please help me, father!
How came you here, brother?
This is the wrong side of town for you.
Oh.
Oops.
Nice one.
Bye!
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
alone we have saved wrong side of town for sure i don't want to be here i can see why they say don't come here i should have heeded their warning oh there's more of them why didn't i heed their warning yeah boy oh where'd he go There was a guy here for sure.
We reached a new checkpoint.
Hallelujah.
I'm feeling the holiness of this church.
That's like...
Ow!
Golly.
What is that?
This is special looking.
Nothing.
You know, I should have remembered how the good old-fashioned way of taking care of a head crab is just smacking it.
Just smacking it.
Oh, I gotta take out my aggressions real quick.
Are those not goods for me?
Oh, there are things to throw, I suppose.
What the?
I got yeeted from the room.
I don't make me go outside again.
Downstairs.
Smackdown.
Not even you can stop the power of the crowbar.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm pressing four.
I guess I'm out.
Woof!
Crowbar!
Supremacy!
Okay, so they both go outside.
Just one goes...
Ouch!
Holy moly, I took a lot of hit.
One goes down here and one is upstairs.
Let's check out here first.
Wait, where am I?
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, upstairs.
Can I have some more ammo?
Or is that too much to ask?
Oh, gosh.
I'm
just running anywhere at this point.
The delayed explosion was mocking me to like the unth degree.
Anymore?
Where is he?
Oh, no?
What?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my god!
About 1 HP again!
Let me up.
She's not gonna make it!
I hear I'm running.
Holy cow.
I'm just gonna run for it.
health somehow from
oh they call me crazy I care not for thou art my helper my strength and my Savior yeah I will send the cart for you brother it will be but a moment oh no patience brother oh guard yourself well oh it's a oh Oh!
It's one of these types.
Oh my gosh, the way it's shaking.
Keep yourself well stocked, friends.
There's two of them.
Maybe?
I probably don't need to be using two at once, but you know.
Two of them.
Here it goes!
The car!
okay this isn't so bad so far it could be worse it could be way worse is
it on its way is it the slowest card ever
um hold on I'm in the cart I saw it for once I'm here I'm here We've made it!
That wasn't bad at all.
I thought it was gonna be like an absolute swarm.
Oh my god, father!
Greetings, brother.
Oh, father, father.
And so we meet at last.
Father.
You are to be commended for avoiding my traps.
The work of a man who once had too much time on his hands and now finds time for nothing but the work of salvation.
wish to remain in raven home so i will show you to the mines i'm so relieved as for me the shepherd must tend to his flock especially when they have grown unruly follow me brother and tread lightly for this is hallowed ground over here brother hold on i'm just exploring a key quickly brother Oh,
okay.
I can't explore anything at all.
Oh, okay.
Beep, beep, beep.
Hello, brother.
Oh, why did I fall off?
I didn't even touch anything.
Over here, brother.
Uh-oh.
I wish I had...
Oh, my gosh.
Do I have to protect?
We're fine.
He can die?
No way.
Escortment.
Why does he keep pushing me off the low?
Why am I sniping with a shotgun?
I don't mind these guys so much, I say.
I was like...
Ouch.
You know what?
Let's not do that.
Here I was gonna try and...
Save my ammo.
Leave me alone.
You too.
Don't worry.
I actually have a plan.
This works just as effective.
Yeah!
Some good teamwork there.
Where'd my friend go?
Where the hell did that thing come from?
Okay, I hope this works.
Oh, they're throwing...
Ah, sorry, brother!
So sorry.
So sorry, brother.
I need to be a little bit careful with those.
But look, it's all on fire.
They're all just going to catch on fire.
It's I made my own trap.
See?
They do catch on fire.
Eventually.
It works.
Whoa, today.
I've put you.
Get you out of your misery.
Oh no, our trap!
Okay.
Oh, I thought we were leaving?
Oh, we are leaving.
Okay, just kidding.
Can I hurt him?
Or...
May
the light of lights be with you!
Oh, um, I thought I saw...
Oh.
Where'd it go?
Yeah, boy!
I lose it every time.
There it is.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, you're holding out on me, mister.
Okay.
Oh, where'd he go?
Mr. Oh, my friend?
Hurry while I hold the gate.
Oh, quickly.
Ow!
Oh my gosh!
Ah!
I'm trying!
Where do I go?
Thanks, mister.
I needed that.
Farewell, brother.
I fear I deliver you to a darker place.
May the light of lights illuminate your path.
Wait, are you gonna die?
No, he's fine.
Look to your own salvation.
Salvation.
Father!
Oh, he's still alive in there.
I like how you can see where, like, the bombs drop that, like, released the head crabs.
Oh, God, no!
He's so awesome!
What's over here?
His laughter rings throughout the hills.
Oh
my gosh.
Did I survive?
Am I out of that town?
Almost.
Almost there.
Just in case.
How do I get that one?
Now the drop.
We're just dropping.
Where are we dropping, boys?
Oh, he's...
Major fraction detected.
Carefully.
Oh.
Well, I didn't see where else to drop.
Legs broken.
There's no other way to do it.
We beat you!
redirect
that didn't do anything okay i think i just drop uh here oh my gosh don't fall
it's nasty down here
i'm gonna save
what's that
Oh!
To himself, thank you so much!
Wait.
Good time to mention this cancelled Half-Life 2 spin-off Half-Life Ravenholm that would have had you return to the iconic ghost town as Adrian Shepard.
Who's Adrian Shepard?
Ticcup, thank you!
Thanks to the gifted!
Thank you!
Poseidon, welcome back!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, whoops.
Please work.
Oh, I think I actually got a guy.
Oh, man.
They noticed me.
I like how they bump into each other.
It's kind of cute.
Those zombies here, so crowbar should be fine.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, wait.
Now I'm going to go back this way.
Figure out where I need to go.
go from here.
Okay, everything just looks like I need to drop.
But that's scary.
So I'm just going to avoid that until it's... Okay, that... Now I must.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, love that.
It's not that bad, you say that.
But I'm frightened!
I'm quite frightened, you know.
Whack!
I died immediately.
Can't patrol.
Thank you so much for the tickets!
Thank you.
Okay.
These guys are kind of tough.
If I fall from over there, do I get damaged?
Hum.
I guess I could try... I don't want to waste all my ammo up here, you know?
I think that'd be kind of silly.
Rip.
Dodge them?
Let's just... Yeah, you know what?
I saved, so what?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm dodging, I'm dodging, I'm dodging, and running, and dodging, and running, and dodging, and running.
I'm dodging, I'm dodging, I'm dodging, I'm dodging, oh!
Oh my gosh.
That didn't work.
I was just scratching my nose, please.
Give a girl.
Take out those guys as quickly as I can.
I don't know where to go.
That's the only issue.
Oh my gosh.
I
saw some health over here.
Oh, but I can't get in there.
Wait, was I...
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Stop it.
I'm trying to just go and climb the stairs.
I didn't think it was in here.
Because I can't go anywhere from here.
Oh, I can.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Ah, this is where it puts me!
This is so evil!
You can't be serious right now!
Ah!
Oh my goodness gracious.
That was so evil.
Did it shoot it at me?
Nice!
Trick shot.
First try.
Alright, let's see.
I think, guys, I'm gonna call it there for today.
Rip Gret.
Oh, my brain is feeling so...
But I think I will.
Call it there.
Oh, uh...
And yeah.
Ravenholm is a stressful map!
Holy moly!
I am so- I'm so- I was already tired starting this.
And I feel tired still, but...
Like, I feel like I ran to- I'm about to hit the chapter end?
Oh, am I?
Okay, then we'll- we'll go to the chapter end.
I'm guessing down here.
Yeah?
Maybe?
Yes.
Okay.
If you say I'm about to hit it, then I'll go until we hit it.
That's not a guy, is it?
Oh, I think it is.
Did he need me to go up there, though?
Actually.
Look, Gordon.
Gropes.
Or do I go through here?
No.
Oh wait, I go around it.
I'm stupid.
My bad.
There's dead people no matter where you go.
Okay, that should take care of anything up there.
And it comes back down.
Wait, huh?
Oh.
I didn't realize I was so close to it.
Run after it.
Okay.
Oh!
Too soon?
Oh gosh.
I should have ducked.
Okay.
I understand.
Not what they meant by half-life.
Yeah, I need to crouch.
I understand now.
Oh my gosh, I'm trapped on it.
crouch oh i'm trapped
guys i feel like nimi yesterday i got stuck on them though that was unfair there was an attempt
i'm just running oh i made it
Is this...
This is what we mean by end of chapter?
Please, God no, I'm so sick of you guys.
The sun!
I know!
We finally are out in the sun!
More guns.
But I'm full.
Good place to stop.
Wait, but it's not the end of the chapter?
There will be a chapter title.
Oh, that's right.
Why have you guys...
Why are you guys here, too?
This is the best stopping point.
Okay.
Then we'll stop here.
Let me actually do a hard save.
Okay.
Well, thank you guys.
thank you thank you for uh for more half-life too and um next week uh is mgs con so i won't be playing on friday uh probably sometime earlier next week so oh my god thank you for the pink thank you thank you um miss lots cuz work but looking forward to watching the vibe but know why they don't go to I don't want to go to Raven home either.
I don't want to go back.
You guys were right to be so weary.
But this was a lot of fun.
I don't know.
Maybe if I...
How much do I have left of the game?
If I do a bunch next week, will I finish?
Still a lot?
Wait, four to six hours is not a lot.
A lot.
Okay, never mind.
Then we have a lot, a lot.
Okay, cool.
Two thirds.
People are saying 20 out.
I can't tell.
Ten hours.
I'm getting ten hours.
I'm getting four hours.
Do you guys know how to tell time?
And then some people are saying I'm two thirds of the way in.
Some people are saying I'm a third of the way in.
Some people are saying I'm halfway in.
I don't know if you guys have ever looked at a clock before.
A hundred hours.
Time for new outfits on karaoke.
Yeah!
It'll be just a little bit of karaoke outfit tomorrow.
So, um, yeah.
We will do it.
I have stuff to prepare.
So I will go do that.
Otso Vito, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
And I will see you guys when I see you next.
Thank you, everybody.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Bye-bye.